I remember and I was like and if you
don't mind speaking to Lisa Myers of NBC
because all those years ago I was
actually hosting a show on MSNBC and I
remember when she came forward with that
report and she had to fight to get that
on the network and I had to fight to be
able to talk about it on MSNBC I did I
got into a huge fight with MSNBC
executives at the time because they
didn't want me to run it on my show at
the time they didn't want me to go near
you at the time and I think you came on
with me yeah but don't you remember when
britt hume and all of the men around him
and women were wearing free Lisa Myers
buttons oh I don't know if you remember
that or not really yeah yeah that's what
we had reporters who are actually
willing to go to the mat do you think
when needed after all this time there
will be any you know whatever there's
not justice coz it's not a legal case
but there will be some type of
comeuppance for the Clintons or it's
just just a momentary thing here Oh
Laura I yeah I hope so I hope that they
finally get what to do to them you know
that's why I was so enraged yesterday
when Chelsea Handler tweeted what she
did and why I came back and tweeted what
I did you know she needs she supported
my abusers in the 2016 presidential race
and I wanted to say to her I met her too
you know all victims matter it doesn't
matter if you're a Democrat or a
Republican or if you're yeah who cares
or if you're a if you're straight or if
you're or if you're gay or if you
believe in God or not we all have the
right to be believed and wanita we
actually have a full screen I think of
that tweet that Chelsea Handler that
totemic intellect ah
imagine being molested by an older man
she said then that man denies ever doing
it and goes on and gets elected to rise
state Senate I know what kind of message
does that send
and then you well you tweeted back at
her you know hello
remember basically remember remember me
and again a lot of these people have
very short term memories I'm glad you
took her on Juanita I apologize for
audio gremlins but we'll have you will
have you better thank you so much for
spending some time with us and to
Harmeet and byron for picking up the
slack in the studio